The joe rogan experience.
Well,
a lot of times man and people don't
think about it that way because you
think of morning is like when you have
to go to work.
It's matter.
Human male is this,
what are you talking about?
Come on.
How could that be possible?
You see that in the box?
Taste it.
It's on that box.
It's right on the box.
Oh it fell off.
I know it's missing.
It's probably who.
Wait,
who was here last?
Oh it's probably Dunkins.
Trump does now cause you imagine if you,
what do you want a podcast with somebody
who watched some trim?
The how's your doing as you're doing
like what the fuck are you doing with
those gross thing and then it would be
over somewhere in this area is scanning
the rest of the table.
No,
I'm trying to find that one.
Who smokes joints with random strangers?
Who knows what kinds of fucking weird
fecal herpes you're passing around.
When I put a toenail in my friends bond
once and he hit it and it smells.
That's not a friend of a friend.
You're an enemy posing as a friend.
You're a terrible person.
It burns,
smelled like hair.
Yeah.
Once you go to mechy call going to
Mexico.
Yup.
You down there,
see when I get home.
And that's part of it too,
right?
Part of it too is like the disconnect,
unplug,
unplugging,
and then,
you know,
recharging your brain and being out
there and the desolate surroundings
going 140 miles an hour over bumps.
It gives you,
there's another side of it too that
gives you appreciation.
Not,
you know,
I have,
I have a kid now,
but I know my brother says it to you.
See you down there.
You also see the people,
how they live there.
Our kids,
amazing kids and they live in,
um,
chicken coops,
right?
The blue chicken coop down by a a hose.
They live in chicken coops.
And I'm not kidding,
I'm saying it's a blue chicken coop.
That's what it is.
And there's kids and I actually called,
this is my,
my own little story,
but I,
there's,
um,
the kids that never grew up always come
out of Ohio.
So there's this little road after you
turned down to blue date.
The Blue Gate on the right hand side,
there's a blue chicken coop and it looks
like every year for 10 years the same
kids come out.
They never get older,
they don't have shoes.
They're smiling.
We hand up stickers.
I stopped them,
give him,
I give him candy,
I talked to him.
The heat signs,
autographs,
you take pictures,
you go back the next year they look the
same age and they,
and they live job telling you chicken
coop.
I can draw it for you,
right?
It's,
it's a fucking chicken coop.
It looks like it's,
it's a chicken coop,
but it's not funny.
But you appreciate,
you come back and sometimes you look at
your kids and other people who kids
make,
you have no idea how easy your habit.
Yeah.
And then sometimes the kid,
that chicken,
we'll go to the dump and that's where
they find metal and they find scrap and
they take the aluminum cans and they get
their money and they're happy to,
they're happy.
They don't,
they're not negative.
They're not pissed off.
I think part of the reason was lucky
is I tried to put myself in a position
to get lucky,
which is by playing more.
And believe it or not,
it's van Halen that influence that on
me.
They were playing more than everybody.
They played three blocks from my house
in a backyard.
Now Mani,
I paid $1 to get in,
you know,
the singer Roth was blowing a tube
inside of this guy's drums.
And you know,
I'm going,
whoa man,
these guys are are,
you know,
I was,
I thought they were great and
everything.
And there are plenty of cover songs and
it played a couple of originals I think.
But what I was more impressed by,
at least at that time was how often they
played,
they played every single night.
And I go,
we got to do that if we're going to have
any chance,
you know,
because my thinking was if we play more
than everybody might have to play free a
lot,
but if our name,
you know,
we might be able to brainwash people in
thinking they're supposed to like us.
You know what I mean?
So,
so,
and that's what happened though.
It was that persistence.
It was that playing free,
um,
getting our name out.
Um,
we just happened to be at the whiskey
one night,
uh,
playing,
during the week,
not even a big night or anything.
And,
and the right guy was in the crowd that
lie and he came up,
gave us his card.
And before,
you know what,
we're,
we're recording,
we got air plague.
We don't even have a record deal.
I mean,
we,
our record deal was literally borrowing
15 grand from some guy named Fred.
Hey Fred,
you got 15 grand?
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
but we had a distribution deal.
but this manager,
we had called El and Nivon,
he was from England.
He used to work for virgin records.
He had signed Berlin,
he signed motley crew and a year before
this.
And,
um,
then they would sell these bands off to
big labels.
Well,
he got us on Camy t when we had no deal
and no local bands were on Kamia and
Keller West with no deal.
It was just unheard of.
And,
but that,
I don't know what kind of connection he
had.
So it was just a matter of you being
persistent planning all the time and
this guy saw,
that's such an important lesson for,
for young people who are thinking about
doing something.
Sure opportunity presents itself when
you just fucking buster and dream it and
dream it.
So this is one of the things,
especially talking to college students
that I love bringing up,
which is that,
and I'm the first to admit it,
like I have no fucking clue what I'm
doing 99% of the time,
even especially when I got started,
I still don't know.
And I've,
I've come to realize like,
and I've got,
I've got been lucky enough to meet some
pretty successful,
impressive people.
But like you dig under the surface,
we're all just hacking it.
Like we're all just for expertise,
experience,
those things all help.
But like every one of us is a fallible
human.
All the conventions and rules and status
quo we know were created by other
fallible humans.
And there's no reason not to look at
that and go,
Huh,
does it have to be that way?
Or why is it that way?
And if the reason why is low,
that's the way it,
well,
that's a terrible reason,
you know?
And,
and when you see the world as being that
hackable,
so to speak,
like you start to realize,
all right,
well let's just,
let's actually question stuff.
And,
and for,
you know,
I remember I was a freshman at Uva when
nine 11 happened for this generation of
millennials coming up.
We mow nearly all of us.
One of our first really vivid memories
of the world was nine 11,
this awful tragedy.
And then we get into these two wars and
then think of all the authority figures
we've had in our life since that moment.
They've all at one point another either
misled us,
this sort of deceived us.
Um,
you've got the financial crisis,
you've got the housing bubble,
all these conventions.
Oh,
trust us,
we know what we're doing.
This is the thing,
the American dream is buying a home,
go to college,
take on that student loan debt.
Don't worry,
there's a job waiting for you.
Every single one.
These conventions from,
from all these people in power have not
held up.
And so I think in particular,
millennials,
millennials look at that very
skeptically cause we were like,
all right,
you know what?
So the conventional stuff didn't work
out for anything.
Like we have no choice but to realize,
you know what?
We're all just hacking it.
So let's,
let's really,
let's dive into the passion.
Let's,
let's figure out a better way to do
something.
Not Settle for the way they've always
been.
Okay.